waren sie schon mal wieder im circus
wissen sie das überhaupt noch wie es ist
wenn da tiere durch die manege laufen
oder ein feuerschlucker auftritt auch
dieses gefühl haben wir zum teil
verloren und die gerade den zirkus sind
es wirklich wert dass man wieder in
beachtung schenkt wir haben wirklich
einen dramatischen fall in niedersachsen
und zwar es geht um den zirkus mai und
der weiß überhaupt gar nicht mehr wohin
weil natürlich dürfen auch gar nicht so
viele leute natürlich ein zelt also er
kann allerhöchstens 30 von 250 plätzen
verkaufen das lohnt sich auch nicht und
wir schauen uns mal dieses schicksal an
und es ist der letzte fall in dieser
sendung und der geht gut aus die
verzweiflung ist der nettesten und
akrobaten vom zirkus mai ins gesicht
geschrieben
dem familienzirkus geht es zur zeit der
korona pandemie sehr schlecht
vorstellungen rentieren sich derzeit
nicht weil maximal 30 der 250 plätze
verkauft werden dürfen
hinzu kommt dass der landkreis rotenburg
sie von dem platz haben möchte
auf dem sie seit november leben
es ist ihr winterquartier im
niedersächsischen walde auf dem areal
einer leerstehenden brennerei
wir sind sechster generation zirkus und
unser problem ist dass das ordnungsamt
uns hier raus haben eigentlich sollte
der zirkus seit märz auf tour sein
doch das war wegen der korona pandemie
nicht möglich die truppe besteht aus
acht personen und 50 tieren und sie
suchen nun dringend einen neuen platz
und jetzt immer seit zehn monaten hier
und das ordnungsamt will uns raushalten
also wir müssen gleich erst am ersten
september hier raus und haben geldstrafe
ja und das ist unser problem
derzeit leben sie von hartz 4 und
spenden die angedrohte geldstrafe wäre
ihr oui deswegen sucht die zirkustruppe
nach einem grundstücksbesitzer der
mindestens 6000 quadratmeter zur
verfügung stellen könnte
[Musik]
ja und wie die geschichte weitergeht ich
erzähle ich gleich aber noch mal schnell
zur hand kempkens das ist ja schon
wirklich sehr bitter eine familie
wirklich in großer existenznot nirgendwo
sieht man halt die note mehr als
wirklich bei dieser zirkusfamilie
was sagen sie dazu also wir hören dass
im moment auch von vielen städten
da sind also so schaustellerbetriebe die
quasi quartier machen nicht weiter
können weil es im irgendwo aufstellen
können und die geraten dann in konflikt
mit den örtlichen behörden weil die
örtlichen beraten die plätze haben
wollen die betreiber dort also die die
schaustellerbetriebe dort weg haben
wollen und das ist genau wie hier und
dann werden die vertrieben durch so
bußgeldbescheide durch verfügungen und
so weiter und dabei seien die
schausteller immer ja was soll ich denn
machen wir müssen doch irgendwo
unterkommen
und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass
es ein problem bei der stadt deswegen
ist weil wenn sozialleistungen gezahlt
werden dann muss das die behörde machen
auf deren gelände eben diese
schaustellerbetriebe sind und vielleicht
ist das einfach auch na ja also ein
bisschen ein problem das man da
erhebliche kosten am hals hat seitens
der stadt und dass man dann versucht
irgendwie das anders zu machen und das
ist natürlich für die schauspieler
herstellerbetriebe eine ganz üble
situation ganz schwierige situation ich
meine eigene dass man hier ein auge
zudrücken müsste und auch mehr
entgegenkommen es wird also wir haben
tatsächlich auch mit dem landkreis
gesprochen die wir waren darauf also
dieses gelände ist für zirkus nicht
vorgesehen insofern bleibt es erstmal
bei der strafe und der zirkus muster weg
wie von bild haben aufgerufen wir haben
also ein hilferuf über alle plattformen
versand wer kann dieser zirkus familie
helfen und ich habe schon angedeutet der
letzte fall geht gut aus wir haben
tatsächlich nur noch keine namen nennen
aber wirklich ein tolles angebot eines
betriebes in schleswig-holstein dass wir
auch von dem bisherigen standort gar
nicht so weit entfernt
und da soll man will man diesen zirkus
helfen
tatsächlich gibt es große weideflächen
da gibt es auch urlauberverkehr da gibt
es kinder die sich auch für zirkus
interessieren also da scheint jetzt gut
zu werden wenn es dann vollzogen ist
dann berichten wir natürlich in dieser
sendung auch wieder drüber